I started the podcast because I was  inspired I was inspired to just create  something I wasn't sure quite what but I  started it and I kept going I showed up  for it and that is the secret to the  success of this podcast I just focused  on trying to make the best show that I  possibly could to do it consistently and  to give myself permission to allow  myself to fail and to stay out of the  result so much about life is just  showing up the writers that make it are  the ones who refuse to give up the ones  who just keep writing after they write a  script they don't sit around and wait to  see if it sells or how people respond to  it they just start writing the next  thing you have no control over the  fruits of your labors the only thing you  have control over is the content itself  if you feel stuck in your life right now  maybe you have a creative impulse but  you're just afraid to try something new  my advice  just begin